hey guys what's up i'm so excited for
you to watch this interview before we
get into this interview i want to talk
about our sponsor
prime xbt if you're trading bitcoin
you got to be using primex bt not only
do they have global markets
available to anyone but they also have
great execution
low fees and an amazing user interface
the best part about primexpt is that you
can also follow some of the best traders
in the world
you go on you find someone who you think
is smart and you can literally just
follow their trades when they execute
something your portfolio executes the
same
and if you think you're one of the best
traders in the world then you can simply
go on there and have people follow you
and you earn a little extra income by
having those followers
so if you're trading bitcoin anywhere in
the world you got to use primex vt
they've won multiple awards for being
one of the best trading platforms
in crypto you can trade spot markets or
even use margin
so go on over to use primexpt you can go
to the description and click on the link
there
all right let's get into this episode
today i really hope you guys enjoy this
one
[Music]
all right guys bang bang i've got
jonathan here with me thank you so much
for doing this
yeah yeah happy to be here let's jump
right into your background kind of how
did you get started in the technology
world and what did you do before bitwage
yeah sure so i started my
work life in working sales at oracle
um and you know it was not really
that interesting of an experience i
would say it was more of a soul-draining
experience being there
so i spent a lot of my time learning
about new technologies
and this is uh this is back in 2013.
and i came across a ted talk about the
future of money
and bitcoin was maybe half to a third of
that
of that piece and i found it very
fascinating you know concepts like being
your own bank and self-sovereignty
concepts like more efficient
international transfers
uh and banking the unbanked right these
these were the points that i talked
about
and i was excited so i went deep down
the rabbit hole
about a month later i came out this
obsessed bitcoin guy
right and in 2013
an obsessed bitcoin guy is kind of a
weird awkward thing to be
right um so being known as this guy
someone connected me to another obsessed
bitcoin guy who's at the tech side
uh who's working on the tech side at
oracle and we got together
and we started bitwage so so how we came
up with the concept
is we were looking at what existed in
2013 and what you got to remember
is ethereum didn't exist when we were
first thinking about this
the white paper came out a little bit
after and
so the main thing to think about is what
can we do with bitcoin bitcoin is
going to be the future of money what
doesn't exist
that will have to exist and what existed
back then were exchanges
merchant processors wallets but there
was really
no system for getting money from
merchants
back to their employees or freelancers
or even vendors basically merchants
doing their disbursements
and so we decided let's be the first to
do this
and that if this didn't exist
there would actually be no way for
bitcoin to exist within its own
financial loop
right because the there would have to be
a cash out so this this
was our way to close the financial loop
and have bitcoin
essentially be able to live within its
own ecosystem
so we did that we launched in 2014
um in july of 2014
uh my my partner john and i quit our
jobs
uh about a month before that and
our first product was a company product
companies would sign up
and and invite their workers and pay
their employees to us
and you might realize that 2014
wasn't really a great time to go after
companies for this
this was just after a bubble crash right
i think it crashed from like
a thousand dollars to 400 during this
time period
trying to convince any company that this
is a good idea
that that bitcoin is not just for
hackers and drug dealers
was uh was it was a pretty big challenge
um
and that caused us to create our second
product
which is um essentially a a way to get a
direct deposit account
in the u.s and the eu or the uk and then
you can get paid from any
company that's paying you essentially
globally into those bank accounts and
then you get paid in
in in crypto so so now we have both of
those two
two products uh which actually are each
now worth about 50 of our business both
of them
and there's two different use cases that
are going on
one is the person who wants to get a
percentage of their wage in bitcoin
five ten fifteen percent essentially
dollar cost averaging
and then there are the people who are
actually using this to get their wages
across borders
so we have a lot of people who are
getting paid in like east asia
in south america in india these sort of
places
who sign up with us and then they
actually get their entire wage
through our system and they'll get it in
bitcoin or as a local deposit into their
bank account or something like that
and that's about which today so when you
think about those two different products
um obviously the companies is pretty
well understood
go a little bit deeper on why an
individual would want to get paid uh
in bitcoin other than just price
speculation right in terms of
uh there's plenty of people who say hey
this is cool i'm gonna hold you know one
percent of my assets and bitcoin maybe
it goes up a lot or maybe
it goes to zero uh that's just pure
speculation but then
it seems like there's people who
actually are doing this from a store
values standpoint or
um a efficiency standpoint or censorship
resistance standpoint so talk a little
bit about some of those use cases as to
why people
want to do this sure yeah and i think in
the u.s
that particular use case of the store
value is like i want i'm actually
thinking about this as my savings
account
right the the cash supply of dollars
increased 25 percent last year but my
dollars didn't increase 25
last year which means they're worth less
so i need to now have something else
to store my value right so that that is
one use case
for this uh another another big use case
is
not just looking at it from the
perspective of dollars but from other
local currencies right so you can you
can be
uh in like brazil or argentina
or so you know some other country in
latin america
and you realize that your inflation
is you know been skyrocketing since the
beginning of covet or even beforehand
right or maybe there is a terrible local
economic situation your president got
caught for corruption you just don't
believe in your government
and you don't believe that your currency
can can hold its value
and these people are actually opting to
get their
their salaries completely outside of the
local
their local currencies so these people
will get bitcoin
uh especially if they're comfortable
with it i mean these people know about
bitcoin
you're not getting a a newcomer to get
the entire their entire wage in bitcoin
but then you also get people who are
getting their wages and stable coins
as well and these this is kind of like a
stepping stone
for these people because they're
learning about private
private public key cryptography but
they're not dealing with the volatility
of bitcoin so it's sort of their
stepping stone
they're doing it they're getting away
from the local
um volatility on their own currencies
uh as well and then finally you have the
people
in these countries where basically what
happens in these countries is because
people don't believe in their local
currency the price of bitcoin gets a
premium
when you're trading to the to the local
currency and
that premium doesn't get arbitraged out
because these countries will often have
capital controls that restrict
your ability to transfer your local
currency into dollars
so this premium exists because the
people
understand the value of bitcoin but but
what this does is for our customers
is they actually get to sell against
that premium
because they will for instance export
services to a u.s company
they'll get the u.s price and bitcoin
and then they'll
they'll they'll sell it in the other
country they'll get that premium
uh and we can handle that for them so
that they don't they don't have to
to deal with any of that stuff and in
that case the reason why they're doing
this is so they can get
you know a same-day transfer instead of
a multi-day transfer from
from the us into their bank account and
they can get access to better rates
because
of the the bitcoin premium that exists
in those countries yeah
it makes a uh a ton of sense when you
think through
um the company's side talk about some of
the companies that are starting to adopt
this
um and kind of how it's going for them
sure
yeah so i'd say that in
the beginning of 2020 what we really saw
were more use cases either uh for
cryptocurrency companies coming on or
companies that are doing the
cross-border
and actually you know it was interesting
because even during the bear market
there were companies
doing the cross-border coming onto our
platform
maybe paying like filipinos and indians
or things like that
but now what we're seeing in bull market
is
that companies are are realizing what i
was saying before which is
employees should have an ability to
get paid in a way where they're saving
their wealth instead of
losing their wealth slowly over time by
holding dollars
so companies are coming in and they're
saying we need a
we need a solution to help us do that we
are seeing companies
mostly like startup tech companies
um like for instance recently we had
sequoia
come up there was big nose um that were
that were doing this
this sequoia was actually um a cloud
management company with hundreds of
employees coming on
so we have a lot of interesting clients
from this side but then
we're also seeing really big names
coming in
looking for bitcoin payroll as a
solution you have twitter
you have the miami government that are
both publicly talking about this
about offering it as a solution and it's
really coming down to
the idea that people
should have a way and an option to
get paid in a deflationary currency
where they can store their wealth
forever
and companies want support and so when
these companies are talking about this
are
they talking about um whether they're
using your platform or not
uh paying 100 of the employees salary in
bitcoin is it a percentage is it the
employee's choice
how do you see them kind of adopting it
yeah so
the ability to get 100 of your your wage
in bitcoin i think that
not very many people want to do that
it's pretty scary i mean even i i don't
get a hundred percent of my wage and
in bitcoin i i still do dollars but um
i think that it's the option to do you
know 5 10
15 20 and usually it's the employee's
option
so on our system the way that it works
is you can go in and you can change your
percentage between
any payroll at any point that you want
between dollars
uh bitcoin or maybe stable coins or some
other cryptocurrency
right so you can choose that percentage
and this that's what's being offered for
the company
they don't want to actually touch
bitcoin at all
usually they they uh they
there can sometimes be you know tax
issues
uh involved in like buying a bitcoin and
then sending it off
almost immediately and so we we handle
that
process for them they are funding us in
dollars and then
we are paying uh their employees in
bitcoin there are cases where they do
fund it
in bitcoin but the majority cases i'm a
company
my admin doesn't know anything about
bitcoin i don't want them to like
accidentally
lose bitcoin uh so let's have a service
or we just send dollars and then
the employees choose how they want to
get their their paycheck
absolutely and so when we think through
uh kind of the employer receiving
bitcoin it's essentially dollar cost
averaging right they're just kind of
over time receiving it talk a little bit
about how much
are you guys educating people on that is
that just something that people
naturally understand is that a selling
point to people to take their part of
their salary in bitcoin like how does
dollar cost averaging play into this
yeah so dollar cost averaging is a very
important concept we actually created a
dollar cost averaging calculator called
bitcoin dollar cost average.com
to help educate people about this right
and the general concept is that as long
as
what you're investing in is going to
trend upwards
you don't have to worry about the
short-term volatility cycles
that are occurring when you make the
investment because
instead of doing one bulk purchase you
do small ones over time
so a great example i'd like to think
about about a month ago i was using this
calculator
and i wanted to see what would happen if
i put 250
every paycheck which was twice a month
starting from the height of the 2017
bubble
right um and what would have happened is
i would have invested a total of 18 and
a half thousand dollars
into bitcoin and i would have gotten two
and a half bitcoin
by that time but if i had taken all that
money and by at the very top of the 2017
bubble i would have gotten less than one
bitcoin
right so this is this is you know the
the concept of
if you're afraid that you're about to
buy at the very top
dollar cost averaging essentially
removes the risk
obviously if you're buying at the very
bottom it's better than dollar cost
averaging but no one knows
these things no one knows at the top no
one knows the bottom
i don't know these things so if you want
to get in
and get long-term exposure but you don't
want to worry is at the top is
the bottom dollar cost averaging is the
way to go and getting your paycheck and
bitcoin is essentially the easiest way
to do that
right because you're you're you're
circumventing the process of having to
essentially get
dollars first before doing that
absolutely
i i completely agree um as you think
through
uh kind of the you know just massive
surge of interest
in this um how much of it has to do with
covid
and the move to remote work uh versus
this was just
gonna happen and it's less about uh
covet and remote work
yeah so so where bitwage stands we we
are i
i see ourselves as in the middle of the
two sections of remote work and
cryptocurrency
right because not only do we have this
dollar cost average use case but we have
this international use case where people
are getting paid internationally doing
work for us eu uk
companies and the that
whole that whole remote work uh growth
is really
bringing that sector up additionally we
have the cryptocurrency sector
and what in my opinion is happening in
the cryptocurrency sector is
everything is being lifted by bitcoin
and bitcoin is being lifted by
inflation right the the dollar inflation
i was talking about this earlier
if you look at what happened in in 2020
the the monetary supply increased by 25
percent
if you look at how much real estate
increased i think it was
around 15 if you look at how much stock
increased by the beginning of the year
it was in general i think like s p grew
maybe maybe 30
so it's it's pretty close to the the
number of cash
that was that was that that that would
increase in that time period
um and that's where where cash has been
going
it hasn't been going into everyone's uh
pockets it's been uh and it hasn't been
causing you know food to rise
substantially the price of food to rise
substantially but it's been causing
all real assets to rise substantially
and that's causing
you know the the the movement in bitcoin
so both of these two things
uh kovit was the catalyst for both of
these two things the remote work
and the cryptocurrency industry and
that's why bitcoin payroll is now
really so so hot because you have the
interest in crypto and the understanding
to essentially need to hedge against
your dollar holdings but also
because there's the growth in remote
work this use case this cross-border use
case
is is very valuable right because we all
know that a bitcoin transaction is not
entirely cheap if you're trying to buy
coffee with bitcoin it's it's really not
that easy to do
right now i think you're paying like ten
dollars for that transaction but we're
talking about a paycheck you know
maybe it's it's uh five thousand dollars
or it's you know something like that you
get an entire paycheck across borders
and bitcoin that
that transaction cost is actually
relatively low
and um you know the way that we do the
system we're batching it all we're doing
we're doing batches of the transactions
so the the cost is even is even is even
lower to do
you know a whole batch of bitcoin
transactions to everyone's paychecks
around the world so it makes sense to do
this the the cost savings is there it's
real it's relevant
and it's a real use case for for bitcoin
absolutely when you think through um
kind of just the adoption of this what
numbers can you share with us in terms
of
uh whether it's the number of companies
the number of individuals the amount
that's being paid out just
any numbers that you can share with us
so people can wrap their head around how
popular this is
yeah so we've done about 100 million
dollars in
in payrolls um we have 50 000 registered
users uh on the platform we have people
in over 100 different countries who are
getting paid
what we saw from the beginning of kovid
um so in the beginning of kovid we saw
25
dip in our in our volumes which actually
made sense because
people stopped getting paid during that
time everyone was freaking out didn't
know what was happening
but since that bottom we we've actually
grown
more than 50 percent uh and
it's the the the growth line is looking
really spectacular right now and um
i i think that this this
this trend will just continue because of
this covet catalyst
for remote work and the cryptocurrency
industry yeah
yeah i tend to agree with you uh one of
the uh the arguments people will make is
like why do we have to do this with
bitcoin why don't we just do it with
stable coins
uh do you guys support just bitcoin do
you support other
uh crypto assets and then how do you
think through the pros and cons of
bitcoin versus any other
crypto asset yeah sure so we we have we
have bitcoin
we have stable coins uh and we have uh
we have some other crypto
and if you think about think about like
what are the how we're actually using
these things
so in the us we actually do see people
diversifying from
from bitcoin into other cryptocurrencies
on the cross border
you pretty much only see people doing
stable coins or bitcoin you don't see
people
diversifying in their cryptocurrencies
so much um
and uh so when they
when they're getting paid in in stable
coins again the idea is
they are being self-sovereign to a
degree
um with with owning the coins although
maybe the peg is not a totally
self-sovereign concept
but uh they have more control of their
money than they would otherwise
um but uh they don't deal with the
volatility of bitcoin which is
like the stepping stone for people
because a lot of people they still want
dollars a lot of people in countries
along the world still want dollars and
gives them access to this
um but when we are moving money
from one country to another and then
we're depositing local currency into
someone's bank account we often are
using
bitcoin and not stable coins or some
other cryptocurrency to do that
people think oh why bitcoin is you know
slower or
more expensive but actually bitcoin is
not that slow
and it's not that expensive and the
reality is that it has the network
effect of being really really
liquid so if i wanted to go and sell a
million dollars
worth of bitcoin into a particular
country i can easily do that
and it's not necessarily possible to do
that with
uh other coins with uh with stable
coins uh all at once without kind of
crashing
local prices and getting bad rates so
that's why we we use bitcoin behind the
scenes
because of that that network effect that
it has and the liquidity
that it has then what do you see in
terms of
uh stable coins versus bitcoin like the
adoption like
what do people want and kind of how do
you see that breaking up
yeah so i always think of uh stable
coins as a stepping stone to bitcoin
because bitcoin has
two big barriers to entry the versus the
first is volatility
right and and there's a lot of focus on
that but the the the part that there
isn't that much focus
is the public private key cryptography
right how do you
how do you deal with that how do you
learn about that i mean if you're an
average person trying to get
trying to get bitcoin you've never even
known about this concept before
right and it's important for people to
know because that is the true value of
bitcoin is owning your own money
and thus you have to understand how to
protect your private keys
and what stable coins do
is they they take away one of those
barriers to entry
um and while introducing the other
so it becomes a an easy way for people
to enter the space
right i know about dollars i you know
if i'm in you know zimbabwe or
you know venezuela i i i believe that
dollars
uh is more stable than my than my local
currency so i would love to get access
to dollars that i could use anywhere
um and so uh
stable coin so then they want stable
coins and then they take those stable
clients
and they they say okay how do i actually
hold it how do i actually use it they
learn about
wall you know wallets and private keys
and public keys and all this stuff
and now they know and so the next step
is basically when
stable coins stop being so stable
because
the dollar or some other you know
major world reserve currency stops
looking so stable
and when that happens then it's a very
easy switch to go from
a stable coin to bitcoin so i think that
stable coins are not going anywhere i
think they have a very important role to
what
what's what's going to happen uh around
the world because
not everyone is ready to get a hundred
percent of their wage in bitcoin let's
just be real
um so uh but but people
people you know a lot of people are
ready to get a hundred percent of their
wage in
in in dollars and this sort of gives
people access to
that and um at some point at some point
there will
there will eventually be the move to to
get into bitcoin from there
absolutely uh before i let you go i was
asking everyone the same three questions
and then when we finish up uh you'll get
to ask me one question
uh the first question is what is the
most important book that you've ever
read
the most important book that i've ever
read most important one
well that's part one um i i really liked
i really liked uh a book by italia
calvino called uh if on a winner's
knight uh if if um
uh oh man i actually can't remember the
the name of it after my if if uh
let me look at this
postmodernist writer um uh
uh if on a winner's night a traveler
that's what it is
if on a winner's night a traveler um
and so i read this you know like a
decade ago this book
and it's basically a book about the
journey to
to find uh the end of stories
right um and and it it has two parts to
it like a person who is
uh looking for the story and then the
story itself and right when it comes to
climax
it disappears and it's this this ending
search
to try to to try to find meaning in the
end
of things and it sort of teaches you to
appreciate the
the journey uh and not so much
you know the the end so i i love that
it makes me uh it makes me remember
um kind of uh the enjoyment is in the
process
right not the final result uh which i
think that the grades always
always align on so that's a great
recommendation uh
second question is uh more personal
sleep schedule
um i used to sleep like five or six
hours but uh our friends over
at uh sleep uh have me sleeping on this
completely cold uh kind of
thermoregulated bed
uh it is fantastic i see that little
baby now
and get like eight or nine hours it's
completely changed my life uh
what's your sleep schedule and how has
that evolved over time
yeah i mean i i started off doing six
hours
um at some point at some point in at
some point in college
i i switched to a nine hour schedule um
and what that ended up making me do was
i i was so so efficient in learning that
two days before all my finals i didn't
need to study anymore because i knew
everything
um and ever since then that's that's
what i've been striving for
is is eight eight to nine hours of sleep
and i
i i try to be very rigid about it right
now
during during all the chaos that's
happening it uh
you know uh in crypto and and
at bit wage it's hard for me to find the
time to do that
but um when i have the time
um i'm always trying to get eight to
nine hours
because then i'm at full brain capacity
for the next day
and i always feel better i uh i am
a full convert to the sleep religion i
keep saying that because uh because it
is definitely true
uh last question is more fun aliens are
you a believer or a non-believer
uh i i believe that the chances of there
not being aliens
is basically an uh non-zero
um because uh
you know the the universe is so big
how can it be possible that this this
event of creating life
only happened once i think it's not it's
not possible
have we have have we ever had contact
with alien life that that i don't know i
i
i
i'm usually skeptical when i hear about
people who think that we have had
contact with them
uh yeah i completely agree there my
friend uh before you get to ask me one
question to finish this up
where can people go and find bit wage if
they want
to use it either as a company or as a
employee getting paid
yeah you can go to www.bitwh.com you can
follow us on twitter at
bitwage you can also follow me on
twitter at johnchest or me on clubhouse
at
jonathan chester we're getting the
clubhouse plugs now you're the first
person to plug the clubhouse
on on the podcast i like it i like it
what one question do you have for me to
finish up
um what question do i have for you um
i i wish you had told me i i was gonna
have to come up with a question before
so i could come up with something fun
uh what's your what's your favorite
animal my favorite animal
and why uh probably a silverback gorilla
just cuz ain't nobody [ __ ] with him
[Laughter]
i don't know like i feel like i'm cool
with a lot of animals but uh but the
silverback gorilla just seems like uh
you know
he's one of those that just chills
nobody messes with
and if anyone does they they get
reminded quickly as to why they uh they
shouldn't mess with them
nice awesome all right man listen thank
you so much for doing this i'm a big big
fan of of what you guys are building and
think that uh obviously everyone should
uh should take some portion of
their salary in in bitcoin you guys are
empowering people to do that
so uh keep up the great work and we'll
definitely have to do this again in the
future
yeah thank you thank you thanks for
having me